for amanda and gina their grandfather
jose was like a father to them
he taught them everything helped them
become who they are
and died of the coronavirus one of so
many in arizona
it was horrible to leave him alone and
him knowing we had to leave him alone
like
what was he going through at that time
knowing that he couldn't have his loved
ones there to support him
he was facing everything pretty much
alone and there was nothing we could do
about it
it i i don't know it's
hard but it's very heartbreaking a
situation al asta has become
all too familiar with even after 38
years in the funeral business
with the corona pandemic nothing is
as it used to be
with these families so many of them
haven't been able to be with their loved
one
at the time of death put into a hospital
where they can't visit
or into a nursing home where they can no
longer see them so many people are dying
alone
and that emotionally is challenging for
families uh just to know that they can't
be there and they can't you know be
supportive
and so our our challenge our job is to
help them
kind of deal with that and start to help
them
heal and grieve and that's that's what
we do
more than 2 500 people have already died
in arizona
leaving many hospitals overwhelmed with
the sick
and the dead
when we get a death call the hospital
will say can you come quickly because
our cap we're at capacity we don't have
anywhere to put these people
they're trying not to get to these
mobile units but they actually are
so when we go now to a hospital transfer
someone in our care
they have to actually have to look and
see where the body is is it in the
hospital facility or is it out in the
mobile facility
it's been a little over a week since
they buried their grandfather amanda and
gina still need
time to come to terms with their loss
but they already have strong feelings
about who
is to blame they could have handled it a
lot better i feel
they knew about this from jump and they
did nothing
i understand price so the world wouldn't
go in panic mode but at the same time
look what's going on
look what occurred due to them knowing
and not doing anything about it
and i really do feel they could have did
a lot more to help a lot of people and
people are still getting sick people are
still going to the hospital people are
still dying and i don't understand why
i just don't and i don't think it's fair
to any of us
their feelings are shared by many
mourners in america
that the lack of leadership from the
white house is
just as dangerous as the virus itself
the beaches of miami's south beach are
largely deserted these days
rain here to stay for at least a week
according to the u.s national weather
service
will probably keep floridians from
gathering in large crowds at the beaches
and that's a good thing because miami is
the new epicenter of the corona virus
crisis in the u.s
breaking records of new covet 19
infections on an almost daily basis
we meet up with dr garrett daniel pust a
trauma surgeon at jackson memorial
hospital in miami
he's treating more and more coronavirus
patients every day
dr poost is practically begging people
to change their behavior
the most important thing is everybody
has to wear masks you have to wear a
mask there's no way around it
social distancing is very important to
stay at least six feet apart
frequent hand washing hand hygiene is
very important we cannot have right now
large gatherings of people the miami
jackson memorial health system
four hospitals in total had 167 covet
positive patients
at the first infections peak back in
april now
doctors and nurses here are dealing with
400 covet patients
and every day that number grows most
difficult
problem is that you know the patients
who get admitted to the hospital are
very sick they need a lot of support and
critical care
and there is an infinite there's not an
infant enormous of icu nurses
and physicians as the number increases
the number of hospital emissions
increases the number of
icu requirements increases and the
number of deaths will go up
as the largest county hospital in all of
the united states and the biggest
provider of healthcare in miami
other parts of the hospital have to be
converted into covid icu
units as quickly as possible that's a
major challenge
as it severely impacts other medical
fields and services the hospital
provides
the core of what i do is that you have
to see the patient 20 times a day to
make sure that everything
is working out well now you're in a
situation where the patients have to be
isolated
you cannot go in and out 20 times go to
different patients
that's really a stressful
situation to just change the way
you practice medicine and to
you know to be still be comfortable that
you're doing the right thing and provide
the services that
patients deserve despite many please
from a majority of healthcare
professional and medical
scientists the republican governor of
florida ron desantis
has so far resisted calls for a mandate
on wearing masks
and he strongly opposes suggestions for
the need of another shutdown
the city of miami however is reportedly
contemplating a new
shelter in place or shutdown order
however
for now and effective immediately the
mayor ordered miami residents and
visitors
to be fined fifty dollars without a
warning if they are caught
not wearing a mask anywhere in public